bobsledding is a winter olympic sport  where you have your driver and you have  a brakeman which is my position the  brakeman is mainly the engine to the  sled we get it going as fast as possible  i am asia evans and i'm an olympic  bobsledder  [Music]  the track is about a mile long and full  of twists and turns and can get up to 90  miles an hour  the moment i zip up my speed suit i feel  like a complete superhero as almost like  i hear the theme music in my head i'm  ready to go  as we're going to the track picking up  speed we start to pull about five g's  which is five times the force of gravity  so it's literally what a fighter pilot  experiences  it's like someone's jumping on you  because out of nowhere you just feel all  this pressure on your lower back  it's a pretty noisy ride  my head is rattling throughout the sled  i'm trying to stay low  as soon as it's over i can inhale start  breathing again  [Music]  you